the Institute of Directors is urging the
next government to give shareholders
more of a say on pay levels at listed
companies the call made in the business
lobby group selection manifesto is aimed
at helping to restore trust in big
business or Oliver Perry's head of
corporate governance at the IOD and
joins me now so all of it you're arguing
that if 30% of investors opposed a
remuneration report you want a fresh
vote a fresh opportunity for
shareholders to vote absolutely so the
binding resolution on paste the
remuneration policy absolutely now what
we think this will do is this will
inspire greater engagement between the
investors and the board ahead of a
binding vote but I think it would also
ensure that the shareholders fill their
votes count for a lot more at the moment
I think one of the issues we have a
shoulder thing that pages going to get
knowledge through that's certainly what
we've seen in the past so as we enter a
GM season now where there will be a
number of binding resolutions as there
was today at Barclays I think it will be
interesting to see how shareholders
engage and we think this is a good way
to ensure that shareholders and boards
engage more well since you've raised the
subject of Barclays one in seven
shareholders failed to vote for just
only the CEO to be reappointed what's
your reaction to that well look and
clearly he's made some errors certainly
around the whistleblowing he's
acknowledged that but he is an
experienced financier he understands the
banking world better than anybody else
and it was a matter for shareholders and
ultimately he's going to be judged on
the financial performance financial
performance of baldies has met in has
been in line with management
expectations now over the next 12 months
he's got to justify his reelection to
the board but looking back at some of
your proposals I mean do you really
think that trusts in big business is so
broken that we need to go this far I
think we've had a number of corporate
failures over the last couple of years
whether it be Sports Direct or the issue
with BHS and
identified by mark the accounting
scandal at BT so I mean absolutely this
affects the perception on British
businesses as a whole and our members
are concern about it and so it's
absolutely crucial that we restore trust
in business and we think this is the one
way we can do it you mentioned BHS sir I
mean BHS is unlisted I mean in private
you essentially want a beefing up of
rules surrounding private companies as
well I mean how do you enforce that Toby
difficult isn't well well the code of
governance that operates in the listed
market it operates on a complier
explained Bay
so what we would actually encourage the
government to do is actually look at
developing a code of governance for the
understood markets as well and you could
do it in two ways we have our own
unlisted guidance which we published six
years ago which can be used or the
government could choose to use the UK
corporate governance code and
cherry-pick the relevant parts but how
do you enforce it though I mean you know
good luck trying to tell so Philip bring
her how to run his company sure there
are some difficult personalities than on
the illicit sector just as there are on
the listed sector but the codes operate
on a complier explained basis so where
companies choose not to comply with the
regulation they would have to explain
why not and we see a government playing
a key role in that perhaps in charging
the regulator the financial reporting
Council to be some sort of enforcement
body the FRC have been pretty toothless
thus far the hum they hum in though you
know they don't exactly put the fear of
God into companies well they're
toothless because they don't have the
powers to actually act so if you look at
some of their remix on the accounting
issues they do have very sharp teeth and
they can they can find accountants they
can ban accountants on corporate
governance they they met they are merely
custodians of the code what they've
actually called for is a beefing up of
powers so hopefully the government will
look at that very closely and briefly
what sort of response to expect from the
government I'm confident that the
government will look at our proposal
very very closely all options on the
table they've published a green paper
into this so hopefully we'll be
considered along with that